[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre sur tv soixante
dix huit pour un nouveau point sur
l'actualité yvelinoise en cette période
de confinement est tout d'abord un point
sur la propagation du code vide 19 dans
le département à ce jour 8 190 personnes
sont hospitalisées un chiffre en légère
diminution tout comme pour le nombre de
patients en réanimation 136 à des
chiffres communiqués par santé publique
france rappelons qu'en france dans
l'hexagone plus deux à vingt mille
personnes sont décédées dans le cadre de
cette pandémie opération distribution de
masques
aujourd'hui en faveur de 300 commerçants
de trappes par l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines chaque commerce
ouvert a pu recevoir un lot de 50
protection la distribution s'est tenue
en présence du maire de la ville dit
malandain depuis plusieurs jours
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines va aussi à la rencontre du
personnel soignant ou encore des
pharmacies pour distribuer des masques
qui proviennent de la région écouter
othman nasri au total a aujourd'hui 10
millions de masques déployés sur toute
la région et nous en avons commandé 30
millions au total
cette semaine l'ensemble des commerces
actuellement ouverts dans cette période
de crise sanitaire sur saint quentin en
yvelines seront approvisionnés avec
cette dotation de masques fournis par la
région ile de france sous leur
fournissons aussi le guide qui a été
réalisé par l'agglomération qui contient
le récapitulatif des aides qui sont à
leur disposition qu'il s'agisse du fonds
de solidarité de l'état et de la région
pour ceux qui connaissent des baisses
importantes de chiffre d'affaires ou des
garanties d'emprunt qui sont aussi à
leur disposition
et là aussi le service développement
économique de l'agglomération est à leur
entière disposition pour leur venir en
aide pour passer ce moment difficile
lancement aujourd'hui de l'opération
hashtag mon printemps 2020 par
l'académie de versailles une opération
qui doit permettre aux élèves de prendre
du recul sur le confinement en ayant
recours à l'art sous toutes ses formes
les explications bonjour à tous je me
présente phase danseurs hip hop et
chorégraphe de la compagnie
matic
[Musique]
j'ai à peu près une minute pour vous
parler du projet non printemps 2020 dans
lequel je vous présente mon challenge
est numéro un on vous inspirant des
gestes barrières créer votre propre
chorégraphie préventive stop kovy 10 mhz
comme cet artiste ils sont nombreux à se
joindre à l'opération mon printemps 2020
lancée ce 22 avril par l'académie de
versailles
le principe est simple en artiste en
défi libre ensuite aux élèves en
autonomie ou avec leurs enseignants
s'ils sont investis dans l'initiative
d'y répondre
théâtre cinéma photographie musique
danse tous les arts sont concernés
et puis nous allons faire en sorte que
nos jeunes s'intéressent à des
thématiques qui sont particulièrement
importantes en ce moment le temps qui
passe la mémoire le 2 dans le dehors la
liberté la solidarité la solitude
ce rendez vous permettra aux plus jeunes
de prendre du recul sur cette période de
confinement mais aussi d'en garder une
trace en souvenir
cette création après l'ouverture
individuel de structures de résilience
dans cette commune était là mais
j'insiste beaucoup aussi sur le côté de
sa vertu dans leur rapport à la société
si l'épreuve collectif on vit et on
trouvait ça très intéressant et
important de connecter la l'expérience
individuelle la création individuelle
avec la société avec le reste du monde
parmi les partenaires
l'opéra national de paris le musée
national d'histoire naturelle ou encore
le réseau ile-de-france des musiques
actuelles
la plateforme l'umih point fr relaiera
les créations d'artistes et d'élèves une
publication sera également fait sur le
compte instagram mon printemps 2020
l'opération se poursuivra jusqu'à la fin
du confinement mais elle pourrait se
prolonger les mois suivants en fonction
des résultats
relancer les salles de cinéma dès
qu'elles auront l'autorisation de
rouvrir leurs portes c'est l'objectif
d'une entreprise yvelinoise posée au a
basé à chambourcy elle est spécialisée
dans les chèques loisirs l'échec cinéma
pour les entreprises et les comités
d'entreprise et face à la crise
sanitaire elle a lancé l'initiative
j'aime mon cinema.fr au motif des
sponsors donc des entreprises privées
des des grands marques nationales des
distributeurs des banques des assurances
à offrait enfin les stimule à offrir des
places pour la nourriture des salles
donc en gros il offre une place de
cinéma à leurs clients leurs
collaborateurs ou leur partenaire et non
en offre une deuxième il ya un
formulaire d'inscription qui permet de
s'inscrire en ligne
on a les équipes sont mobilisées
pleinement sur ce projet donc sont
extrêmement réactive il faut pas hésiter
à demander des informations si elles
sont importantes
on délivre également un label qui est un
label jeu de soutien du cinéma français
pour l'année 2020
en échange de cette initiative
évidemment qui réutilise à pour par les
entreprises pour mettre en valeur leur
apport dans la société dans une
situation aussi particulière que ça il
ya pas mal de gens je sais qu'ils
cherchent des idées pour se rendre utile
à la communauté en ce moment et on
fabrique pas tous des masques et des
gels hydroalcooliques donc la culture et
notamment le patrimoine
cinématographique française c'est un
sujet qui fait réagir énormément à
l'heure où on se parle actuellement on
est à 180 milles places qui ont été
validés par nos partenaires pour la
réouverture des salles donc pour moitié
la moitié ont été offertes par groupes
aux libyens ce propos recueillis par
aurélie rond en attendant la réouverture
des salles de cinéma le septième art se
découvre à la maison comme chaque
mercredi nous passons à notre rendez
vous dans vos canapés et c'est avec
bertrand pigné cinéphiles indépendant
qui nous donne ses conseils
puisqu'on est confiné dans nos canapés
je vous propose de continuer à fouiller
sur les plates formes d internet et dans
les plates formes totalement gratuite
il y à une plateforme qui s'appelle
archive.org je devrais dire arxiv.org
puisque certains sites américains
céline internet arxiv de deux des états
unis aux etats unis les droits d'auteur
sont pas exactement les mêmes qu'en
france
et il ya tout un tas de films qui sont
comme les livres en france par exemple
tombé dans le domaine public aux états
unis et qui sont donc disponibles sur ce
site internet arxiv alors il faut taper
à rch
vivéole point org arxiv.org et dans la
petite barre de recherche pas de menu en
haut via une petite pellicule et quand
on clique dessus on arrive sur un site
qui évidemment cet américain évidemment
c'est des films américains qui sont pour
la plupart pas sous titré mais on parle
de films anciens de films noirs des
années 30 40 50 60 50 pas encore
beaucoup 60
on parle de films muets donc de grands
films muets les signes de griffiths par
exemple sont disponibles sur ce site
les films de charlot une grande partie
des courts métrages de charlot sont
disponibles sur ce site et on trouve
également des films totalement
improbable des films contre l'usagé de
la marijuana qui dans les années 50 aux
états unis qui était un grand sujet et
je suis contre les communistes c'est des
films qui permettent de bien rigoler
aujourd'hui parce que c'est un ton une
manière de faire du cinéma une manière
de regarder le monde qui nous paraît
tellement désuète
enfin en tout cas voilà c'est un endroit
dans lequel on peut aller piocher des
choses découvrir du cinéma bis du cinéma
plus sérieux ce qui était réellement le
cinéma deux films noirs des années des
années 50 40 50 des drive all dressed to
kill enfin des films comme ça qui sont
des films mythiques dont on a
probablement un peu tous vu déjà le
titre les affiches etc
quand on s'intéresse au cinéma et qui là
sont disponibles gratuitement
il faut simplement faire l'effort
c'était de regarder le film dans sa
version originale en général dans ces
films là les dialogues sont quand même
pas essentiel c'est surtout pour voir la
qualité de l'offre quoi voilà donc je ne
saurais que trop vous conseiller d'aller
fouiller dans cette mine
aujourd'hui à 22 avril trente septième
jour de confinement les français les
yvelinois se sont adaptés à cette crise
sanitaire école à la maison report du
second tour des élections municipales
livraison à domicile drive également
proposée par certains commerçants
solidarité générosité enfin envers le
personnel soignant le point sur ces six
dernières semaines c'est avec mathilde
2000 au matin du 17 mars les yvelinois
ont découvert des rues désertes
le bruit des voitures a laissé place aux
chants des oiseaux les bars restaurants
cafés théâtres et cinémas ayant fermé le
week-end précédent seuls les commerces
alimentaires les pharmacies et d'autres
magasins de première nécessité sont
restés ouverts en respectant les mesures
sanitaires
mais pour pouvoir se déplacer
l'attestation de déplacement dérogatoire
est devenu obligatoire en cas de
contrôle des forces de l'ordre elle sera
présentée avec le motif du déplacement
bonjour madame
on en est votre attestation s'il vous
plaît cette norme domicile
si elles sont
m'occuper de chasse et michel de
l'association obligé de mourir les
pluies de sonic d'accord très bien
fermeture des crèches écoles collèges
lycées et universités
cette année le brevet le baccalauréat
seront évaluées en contrôle continu pour
les cours tout se passe à domicile les
enseignants assurent une continuité
pédagogique en quelques jours
l'ensemble de notre communauté s'est
mise à faire l'école tout à fait
autrement par exemple dans le premier
degré c'est-à-dire les écoles primaires
on a créé en l'espace de deux jours
l'équivalent de 1700 blog pour que les
enseignants puissent mettre leurs
supports les ateliers de lecture des
moules le programme d'une journée les
petits exercices que les élèves sont
donc vraiment il ya eu un virage
colossal qui a été pris la veille du
confinement lady viennois avaient rendez
vous aux urnes pour le premier tour des
élections municipales
après les annonces du président emmanuel
macron pas de deuxième tour prévu pour
ces élections
les sept communes saint-quentinoise
concernés devons attendre pour connaître
la date du report qui est toujours
inconnue même si le mois de juin était
évoqué le premier tour il est considéré
comme acquis et donc on va prendre des
dispositions pour le report des
dispositions pour les conseils aussi
communautaire d'agglomération pour que
ça puisse continuer à fonctionner ou si
normalement possible et que les services
publics est bien évidemment une
continuité pour faire face à l'afflux de
la maladie dans les 10 villes les
médecins de ville ont organisé
l'ouverture des centres dédiés aux
copies de 19 des centres qui permettent
d'accueillir des patients ayant les
symptômes du coronavirus parmi les
personnes touchées par la maladie on
apprenait le 29 mars le décès de patrick
devedjian président du conseil
départemental des hauts-de-seine qui
avait pour projet la fusion entre les
départements yvelines hauts de seine
dans un communiqué son homologue pierre
bédier président du conseil
départemental des yvelines lui rendaient
hommage et mettait un point d'honneur à
poursuivre le rapprochement des deux
départements
face au co vide les yvelinois ont su
montrer leur générosité leur solidarité
le secours populaire de trappes s'est
mobilisée pour assurer la continuité des
distributions alimentaires malgré la
situation délicate pour les commerçants
des livraisons à domicile ont été
organisées par quelques fermes de la
région des drive ont également été mis
en place dans quelques petites enseignes
vente de livre de café de chocolat les
yvelinois ont répondu à l'appel des
soignants livraison de repas de traiteur
et de chefs étoilés dans des ehpad et
hôpitaux des offres de réductions ont
été proposés chez certains garagistes
des distribution de masques et de gel
hydro alcoolique ont été remis aux
personnels soignants et des entreprises
comme psa à poissy se sont même engagés
dans la fabrication de 10000 respirateur
artificiel
face à cette situation exceptionnelle
notre entreprise s'est mobilisée d'une
part un groupe de travail d'une
trentaine d'experts à étudier la
meilleure façon de produire les
respirateurs plus rapidement et en
grande quantité en parallèle dans la
mesure où dans notre usine de poissy
nous avons mis en place les mesures de
sécurité sanitaire renforcée pour
protéger nos salariés nous avons décidé
d'y installer un atelier pour produire
le bloc central des respirateurs
artificiels le début du déconfinement
est prévue à la date du 11 mai les
écoles reprendront un rythme scolaire
avec quelques changements
les lieux culturels les restaurants
resteront fermées et les gestes
barrières devant être respectées pour
retrouver une vie un tant soit peu
normal les yvelinois devront attendre
quatre semaines pour commencer la sortie
progressive du confinement
fin de cette édition spéciale rendez
vous chaque jour à 19h du lundi au
vendredi pour faire le point sur
l'actualité des yvelines on se quitte
avec des images réalisées par un
habitant de versailles est directeur
artistique de décaler studio il a au
cours de ces derniers jours réaliser des
prises de vue de versailles exempte de
toute vie la vidéo complète est à
retrouver sur internet en voici un court
extrait prenez soin de vous de vos
proches et amis
[Musique]
m